Oh internet you love doing this to me
you know I deep down maybe I like doing
it to myself you think there's gonna be
a release the branner cut I don't know
who's gonna be any kind of those movie
probably not a sequel either let's talk
about it
[Music]
Artemus Wow chill out YouTube it's just
apple juice so Artemis Fowl is a movie
based on the books which I know nothing
about the books so there is that I'm
going into this fresh anything I dislike
about this movie I dislike because I
just abhor the sensation of having my
time wasted so as the movie starts out
is gonna revolve around this super smart
kid is in fact so smart that he only
finds kindred spirits among Stephen
Hawking and Albert Einstein because
sometimes Einstein was right so they're
really hammering home this kids smart
it's gonna come back I'll come back
around to that as to why it's just
useless information it's all right this
kid needs to find his kidnapped dad then
we go to this underground fairy city
where it's kind of like the Santa Clause
if the Santa Clause had no soul
whatsoever also if there's nobody that's
metamorphosizing into Santa Clause but
with the elves and technology as
something reminding me in Santa Claus
only a shitty soulless husk version of
it so now it revolves around this fairy
girl who wants to clear her dad's name
Dame Judi Dench is in it too man you
know she's like I miss being and Judi
Dench is my M by the way I love her as a
point is cats know this so anyhow fairy
girl goes to Artemis Fowl house and then
she's kidnapped by this little sociopath
witch Artemis Fowl is supposed to be
there's a twelve-year-old criminal
mastermind that actually sounds pretty
interesting but I get the feeling Disney
was like look we want to do that but we
need it Disney friendly so it's a clean
sterile Disney friendly version I'm not
saying the books aren't I'm just saying
you could have done a lot more
interesting things with that premise
again I don't know anything about the
books I'm just saying in terms of
premise I get the feeling that Disney
was like Oh interesting but is Artemis
Fowl really does he coincide with our
brand you find talk like that all over
in terms of the entertainment industry
you always hear words like the brand the
IP the brand and everything needs to
coincide with it [ __ ] hell just make
entertainment and now they let our
doorstep this piece of [ __ ] we're really
nothing I mean the beginning of the
movie I was like well I don't hate this
the internet seems
I hate it there are interesting concepts
which I guess that's the point if
there's a crappy adaptation of something
of course it's gonna have an interesting
concept because the execution of the
concept being good is what made it good
in the first place Mortal Kombat
annihilation the movie interesting
concept about out world invading Earth
room yeah it's also done better in well
Mortal Kombat 9 I think that's the gold
standard of the story well you get what
I mean and then I realized nothing
happens in this movie it's just me where
I'm sitting then I'm like well that's
five more minutes that's the oh god is
that ten
oh no that's three minutes god it's just
a movie that drags and doesn't give you
any fulfillment I mean they have to find
this little artifact that essentially
looks like a glowing acorn sweet you
gotta find an artifact spoilers now in
case you're interested in spoilers for
Artemis Fowl you're not you can lie to
yourself don't lie to me you're not but
okay you gotta find this artifact
there is no adventure whatsoever there's
no exploratory element no it's just kind
of she was like all right Artemis Fowl
is in his house I'm gonna go to his
house also this artifact is in fact in
his house hey yeah there is this
fairyland assaults on Artemis fellows
house that they have to hold off but
it's just an action sequence it's
another way of saying things go crashing
boom an action sequence does not equal
momentum this movie never feels like it
gains momentum you constantly feel like
this movie is perpetually in the first
act as movie feels like it's in the
setup phase and then the end credits
roll I'm telling you I was so baffled
when this movie was over I was like
there has to be another act I would
certainly think there is if I didn't
feel like I was here for three hours
which means I was definitely here for
the hour and a half that yep that's
those are the end credits okay I guess
that's the movie early and there's Josh
GAD he comes into the scene militia the
movies narrated by josh gad cuz they
just have to throw a lot of information
at you so like alright we'll use josh
gad to do that yeah look at that cgi you
look out avatar to Artemis Fowl set the
bar nap [ __ ] hell that was terrible
oh yeah about Artemis Fowl smarts I said
we were gonna circle back to it that
makes such a big deal about him being
smart but they never used it what does
he do that's smart
they talked him
with high praise of his intellect his IQ
his genius you get the feeling this is a
smartest person on the planet but what
does he actually do with it nothing he
just he knows to wear reflective
sunglasses when talking to an elf sorry
a fairy not an elf a fairy rocking
Willem Dafoe's Green Goblin outfit from
spider-man I mean that just means you
listen to a lesson his dad gave him
lessons you don't need to be a super
genius to pick up on that I guess he
built a tracking device at the end of
the movie but I'm running out need more
apple juice little more apple juice no
that's way too much all right I'm gonna
head off to enjoy my apple juice point
is folks this movie started out with
interesting enough Lord though it's
being shot at you through a shotgun you
feel like you're the nerd playing
dodgeball and it's all just coming at
you had a hundred miles an hour to be I
say that because I know exactly what
that shit's like it was a soulless
lifeless boring adventure with choppy
shoddy ass editing and it did give me
that feeling that I detest the most and
that is the feeling that I just wasted
my [ __ ] time yeah it's everything you
heard it was it's all that dog [ __ ] mmm
make it better apple juice alright so
Artemis Fowl have you seen it have you
read the books did the movie piss you
off cuz again I heard the movie will
piss off fans of the books I just don't
know how so enlighten me comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more oh
come on
camera froze I don't know why that
happened and as always if you like what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more that's
better
you
[Music]